okay so i think i have allergies because
this nostril won't stop nostralin and
being all runny
um so
i'm busting apart right now
but in continuation of a fun day i guess
tiger was having a fun day because that
[ __ ]
concoction was a mess um i want to take
them to knotts so i haven't been there
for years
i can't even remember the last time i
probably went for like not scary farm
their halloween uh
display i guess where they have like
mazes and stuff and people chase you in
costume and all that um so
i i obviously want damn disneyland but
it's just such
a hassle to book something and
everything's booked out and it's like
ugh so i want to take my notes today
okay so we're about two minutes away
from knott's berry farm but because papa
and i are still
excuse me on our diets
um
we opted for flame broiler that is right
next to knots you see the rides behind
it and then right
right where's my hand right there
is
where frame
flame broiler is at
but this guy over here
get
mcdonald's
he just woke up from a nap
hello and i could smell the yummy french
fries
i don't know
any of this like it's not like
disneyland to me so i don't know
what to do where to go
pick up okay drop off nope
i need to find the parking i scrub her
all the time as a kid oh then you should
tell me where to go but i don't remember
anything because my all the time is
different from other people all the time
well i don't know but usually all the
time means all the time no there's a
difference so like you know when you're
like a rich kid when you go i eat
mcdonald's all the time that's literally
like every day yeah then don't say it
all the time but then if you're a
regular kid then you go i ate mcdonald's
all the time that's like once every week
or once every two weeks you know what i
mean
but when you're really poor and i it
makes noise all the time
that might have been like once every
other month but that's not all the time
well the other time it was air so the
mcdonald's compared to air is a lot yep
whoa you can see the roller coaster over
here how cool
that's not all the time just be like
i've been here a few times i've been
here a few times cool then i won't yeah
okay
kiss me
okay okay kiss me dude
everywhere i'll kiss you everybody
better watch out you gotta watch
[Music]
that's
disgusting eyeballs you have the kisses
but you understand that where is the all
day parking at
well joke's on us the park is over there
we did a big ass roundabout we went all
the way around and now we came this way
so then from here we gotta walk back to
where you saw that sign yeah we just
entered right there on that street when
we first recorded
so we went in a big circle do you
remember when disneyland um parking was
in the front
it was a big ass lot yeah when i was a
kid
yeah i mean what else are you supposed
to remember like as an adult i mean like
that like what i'm trying to imply is it
happened long long long time ago oh yeah
that's how long it's like very like i i
spend more time going to disneyland when
i didn't have that then i did have that
i see i just wanted to know if there was
a memory in there that's all i i
remember where uh um
you didn't even have to do security
checks and all that stuff yeah same i
remember i remember like when you almost
when you like you got on disneyland the
first thing you get to go was that you
know how they have the mickey mouse with
the flowers that everyone takes pictures
with and then it was so fast you could
get a hold of those pictures so fast but
then now it's popping so it's hard to
get a hold of those pictures
we are inside dude which way do you want
to go first let's go
that waterfall
do you know what that character's name
is no snoopy
really yeah let's go check it out
are you nervous
are you a big cat like your papa
42 inches and i'm above it so i should
be all right
yeah well you got to keep looking
so are you ready to be a scaredy cat
so you just did your first big ride
that's a big kids roller coaster how'd
you like it
is it a bit scary yeah
yeah you did look how high that is look
look at that whoa it's bigger than my
do
head
want to do it again or do you want to
take a little break
ice cream okay how about you that was
kind of scary when i when we were going
up that thing i was like i didn't know
how high i was
bit the right right 42 inches it's his
height and then i turned the corner and
i'm like i can't hear you oh when we
turn the corner i'm like what in the
world and it was going up up up up up up
up up and it just started
and the whole time i was thinking of him
though i was like oh i hope he's helping
he's just holding his head up because
his head was like this because you know
when you ride a roller coaster like the
g-force and the way it's moving it like
if you don't have your head
like pushed back against the seat then
it's hard for you to pick it up once
you're like on loops and stuff so i
looked at him he was like this and i was
like
trying to hold it for him this one had
pretty strong g-forces like that it was
okay don't listen to what he says it
wasn't that you guys
yeah how did you like it i know you ever
written a roller coaster that was fun it
was definitely for kids um but it was
fun are you sure it's not for adults it
was definitely for kids
do you want to go again
i'm so proud of you didn't cry
was crying with his kid of course look
at that look this is exactly what i'm
talking about
look at all that
it slowed down dude but what is going
down and spinning all right
it almost went upside down
all right there goes monkey dude
that's a good seat
so now the other way
this thing is so hot
you got it buddy
don't pull it down for you
he's ready he's ready
he's so excited for these he's my
writing buddy yes who's your writing
buddy tycho is gonna be my writing buddy
good
he's so cute man look at those horses up
there
okay
are you sure
i'm so excited for him me too
here we go
[Applause]
see you later
wow
put your hands up take off put your
hands up
i think tiger's face was showing like
when is this gonna end
like towards the end it looks like he
was like wait a minute another one not
another one
good job
i like how tiger's first real roller
coaster is that crazy as one that's like
four stories tall and then we go on
what did you think about that one that's
funny
huh
there he goes
hey dude
such a funny guy
see you later
who taught him that [ __ ]
go up
go up go up
bless you
how was that
is that scary
or just stand right there okay
so one of the reasons why uh knott's
berry farm has kind of like this fond
memory for me it kind of reminds me of
uh you know frontierland from disneyland
yeah but just on steroids
did you like frontierland or no i do but
it's not disney so i don't get what
you're talking about i liked it because
it has a very california feel you know
what i mean i guess it's a very like
woodsy california so it feels very
unique to soul count that's why that's
why it's like nostalgic i see it ain't
disney don't ever say that
so i would like to give shout outs to
myself
because i see this young man with this
delicious slushie
look at that
and you know what
me and my bear
are so disciplined
dude that's it oh my god well then i
gotta even it out i don't wanna i don't
wanna say you're proud of yourself i am
but i i don't want you to i don't wanna
win like that
i wanna you win evenly
but not honestly though i've been really
proud of ourselves
we haven't touched a pizza pretzel
churro nothing what do you mean
so now we are on the grand sierra
terrain
there's cuny
cuny red teeth
this curl is velcroed
okay
are you having fun
[Applause]
okay he's not interested he didn't care
very much
up next
balloon race time dude
that one looks crazy huh you did that
one you're so brave mister
your monkey ready to ride the hot air
balloon do you see that
oh my goodness are you ready
you ready to do it yeah okay let's do it
oh oh oh my goodness what
are you ready yeah oh here we go
here we go we're moving look we're
moving
we are moving we're off the ground
oh here we go here we go
yeah you're smart dude
you're too smart for your own good it's
right
you like it yeah
up and down and up and down
is mama's catching up to us look mama's
catching up to us
okay we're gonna go check out a cave
whoa you're brave look at that
it's a big old cave in there
yeah it is really dark in there and
there's a waterfall too
what
what'd you find a waterfall
hey a waterfall
is it splashing us
okay wait ready
[Music]
hey monkey momma said your butt got
dirty from the waterfall let me see
hey that's a two-sheet
hey that's a little tissue touch
are you supposed to dance like that
how did you get your little butt butt
all wet
how do you feel that your your little
son shaking slowly
you better make us some money out in
public like that i like it
next up
lioness
launcher
oh this one's so fast and scary monkey
hey monkey are you ready this one's
really scary and fast
it's really fast
it's really really fast it's so scary
are you ready
really fast and go upside down too
did you give it away
they both exhaust me so much i'm just
like
oh god
here they go
hi
do it again
do it again
they're sleeping
[Music]
there they go
no no no don't do that
there they go
[Music]
wow
up next
he's so excited i can't i can't do those
i just get way too dizzy just watching
him go round and round
i'm already [ __ ] busy
so i think tigger just wanted to sit on
the big chair i think that's all i
wanted to do
i think that's it okay that's all he
wants go ahead sit on it
that's it
over there
that's all they wanted that was it
so we're just leaving the park we want
to make sure that we leave before dinner
so that we don't have any of these
naughty little temptations and then we
give in to these desires ugh the funnel
cakes
and the fried
chicken breasts mmm
and the juicy cheesy fatty hamburgers oh
uh also taco wants to play with his
cousins and tomorrow's monday so we want
to make sure that we start off the week
not feeling sore because we still gotta
train we're still running our get lean
program uh we're running in today we're
going into week five
which is amazing it's a 12-week program
so we're like
almost halfway there so we just want to
make sure we don't
you know sabotage ourselves by walking
way too much
and now we're all tired and weak and
we're failing at all of our out of our
lifts you know
the three stooges
are back
what color is yours so you got blue
you got red
purple purple what'd you get what color
i don't know
hey i like your twin brother
look at your brother dominic
wait i have a dream
trio trios touch it
we just got back from the park i had to
finish my 10 000 steps and somehow
somehow i don't understand how this
happens but bart's watch what kind of
watch is that
it's one of the most reliable ones it's
a garment
so bart's garmin why is it so reliable
oh okay whatever i just see the [ __ ]
face on him uh so bart has a garmin i
have an apple watch
and um we do track our steps on our
watches but his is always more advanced
than mine in terms of steps i don't know
if the watch i guess the watch would be
more advanced because this is not made
specifically for that this is just made
for a bunch of fancy stuff that one is
made for like trails and it's made for
like really small things like i don't
know like climbing the himalayas or
something
uh anyway so yeah he's probably way more
accurate than mine
but somehow he's always like we had the
exact same day today minus him walking
to the back to do some laundry
um but other than that we had the exact
same day he was at nine thousand steps
when i was only at six thousand so i
have like working you ain't working
probably so as the kids were playing at
the park and he was watching them i was
just walking laps and i was walking in
my trusty
barbell brigade slides i've been really
enjoying being barefoot because i feel
like my foot gets to be in its natural
what up dude
you got a yellow popsicle
it gets to be in this natural state like
like it's not like um squeezed into the
shoe that's making my foot
conform to this odd shape even though
it's not really that really that odd but
i have a wide foot so i've noticed the
more barefoot i am the
more like my feet get to expand and just
look more like you know just regular ass
feet instead of them just getting all
squished and narrow
so because of that i really do enjoy
walking in slides and it's like a slight
just like a regular walk like like
you're not out of breath or anything so
just got back from that hitting 10 000
steps
what's going on i just don't want the
you know some of this stuff gets stuck
to the lid
um
unstick the lid are these the last of
your macros this one says july 8th oh no
it's scary
it's dairy juice what do you think
smell it it is also yogurt so it's
already pre-fermented right i don't know
i don't like to all right
i don't want to waste it
[Music]
oh it smells
okay cool
all right so tune in for tomorrow's vlog
when i talk about bart having to [ __ ]
his life away
just kidding but no really please tune
into tomorrow's vlog
because i'm done for today i'm so
tired and i feel like i have a bunch of
allergies so i'm going to drink some
lemon ginger tea because i have this
nostril that just keeps running i keep
sneezing huh who loves you enough to
make it for you mom
bart's making it for me
um yeah i feel like i have allergies
keep sneezing
runny nostril so i'm gonna try to like
kick up my immunity just a notch
but
i need to really rest
see you guys tomorrow